une défaite en quarts de finale des
play-off qualifié sur le fil pour la
challenge cup le tours volley ball veut
tourner la page d'une saison grise et
même noir pour certains
alors quand il tient une nouvelle pépite
le club le fait savoir l'international
français kévin tilly a été présenté à la
presse aujourd'hui une recrue
expérimentée qui doit permettre au club
de prendre un nouveau départ lucas
chopin nouveau départ pour le tvb le
club de volley ball a fait le deuil de
sa saison de ligue à vierge de trophées
et va désormais de l'avant c'est un
joueur d'envergure qui a été présenté en
conférence de presse aujourd'hui passés
par l'italie la chine ou encore l'équipe
de france avec qui il a notamment été
champion d'europe kevin tilly a été
séduit par les projets tourangeau tour
m'a fait une belle proposition ne faut
pas le cacher et c'est j'ai l'habitude
de venir à tours on a fait beaucoup
stage ici donc je connais je sais que
c'est un club très organisé enfin très
professionnel et c'est ce que je voulais
je voulais trouver quoi c'est un des
clubs les plus prestigieux de france
pour sa prochaine saison le tvb affiche
des objectifs clairs redevenir champion
de france remporté la challenge cup seul
titre européen qu'il manque à son
palmarès et remporté la coupe de france
pour autant la direction du club reste
prudente
oui on est positif mais après attention
attention on en passe et en était
positif on a été grevé par les blessures
les départs donc pour espérer qu'on
puisse commencer une saison normalement
oui aussi avec du public et surtout du
public parce que cette salle avec
l'équipe que nous allons présenter son
public ça serait ça serait un crève
coeur
l'effectif du tvb pour la saison
prochaine est désormais bouclée de
nouvelles annonces d'arrivées de joueurs
seront faites dans une semaine